eric fetty to the hill today and against
the cubs it'll be career start number
two
and rafael ortega will lead off against
eric fetty he's been a hot hitter
swinging a drive right center field
toward the alley deep and that ball is
going to be off the top of the wall is
it a home run it's a home run for rafael
ortega it has ruled a home run and the
cubs lead one to nothing on a lead off
homer by rafael ortega
3-2 in a swing and a miss
fetty keeping the fastball away
and looks like wisdom got caught
guessing
right out over the plate and a couple
decays for eric fetty
and the grounder after the ortega home
run
albert also lie his 19th start underway
4-11 with the
4-7-3 era
as the rain comes down a little bit
harder now folks getting out the gear
chain jump swung on and missed strike
three beautiful pitch there to get the
strikeout
duffy
rough at bat
three consecutive strikeouts now for
eric fetty
oh
that's really hard hit
and
running catch yadio hernandez ball had a
gear to it and he had a pretty quick
gear going himself
betty comes back to strike out al conor
of his fourth strikeout
here's a swing and a mess on a change-up
strike three good pitch second strikeout
for alzheime
well strike three call
out zelay was reacting like it was two
feet inside on this belt buckle
but he's going
pretty good jump ball bounces
outstanding pickup and all in one motion
tag
by adrian sanchez that was pretty slick
it might have been easier to steal when
it was just wet out but you put all that
turf is on the field now you're you're
running in like a plowed field it's hard
to get
a jump look at all that diamond drive
they just put on flying up in the air
great pick by adrian sanchez
and keeping his glove low not really
moving it up
oh breaking ball had him frozen
betty 11 batters six strikeouts
and rivera slams one by
wisdom at first
[Applause]
rene rivera hasn't played much since
becoming a net but he's now three for 12
playing in his fourth ball game cubs won
nationals nothing rivera the tying run
at second juan soto now the go ahead run
it first pick your poison it's josh bell
what a stroke the other way
here comes rivera around third haps
throw
wide everybody trying to move up
bella hook slide another runner coming
home
the nats running the cubs around the
infield there and it's a 2-1 lead that
was exciting
robinson torinos comes out for the throw
and tries to get bell at second base and
then nobody's covering home watch
and want sort of says oh nobody's there
so here's yadiel hernandez who has eight
hits in his last 14 times up
and that's a knock
and here comes bell the nat's lead three
to one
first pitch this time
sanchez there's your one two three
shutdown
[Applause]
sanchez rivera fetty straight ahead
rivera to third row blaze to second and
josh belligen
that is a base hit
rivera scores
and then ants will take a 4-1 lead
3-2 again
that ball drill
pretty nifty pickup by duffy out there
that's the third baseman who just moved
to that very spot
all right check out eric fetty's day so
far doing a real nice job so 61 pitches
34 strikes did not let the lead off home
run rabbling just settled in nicely and
now he's got a 4-1 lead
3-2 one out still
betty
that cutter
looking good strikeout number seven
today
oh he serves one to right
[Applause]
two hard hit balls that way today
and kibum has his third base hit in nine
at bats in this series looked like he
got a cutter slider
went down and got it
took his bat about halfway to first too
i don't know if he could stick it to his
hand here
keep him on the move hit and run look at
this
he's going to touch second and keep on
going
love what the nats and davey martinez
did right there
executed to perfection
duffy
to second for one double play cubs
takes care of the threat five complete a
three-run nationals lead
hard hit ball and his dream weekend
continues
raphael having another good day with a
homer and a single
ortega
launches that one deep right back it
goes and that will find its way out
rafael ortega a double shot today for
the cubs and it's a one-run game
[Applause]
and he well
pulls out the big curve ball
to end the day eric fetty 108 pitches 62
strikes three runs on two hits
in six struck out eight second highest
total of the season
there's yadiel over his last four games
six for ten four batted in
that's well hit left field line slicing
c
u
later
his third homer and the nats have a two
run lead yeah dl
solo in the first a two run shot in the
six then he's got contreras aboard here
in the eighth here's the 3-2 swing and a
drive into right field deep if it's fair
that ball is going to be
gone for a home run can you believe it
raphael ortega has just built it his
third home run of the game the ball game
is tied at five and the cub fans at
nationals park are dancing in the aisles
five five as it goes to the bottom of
the ninth
left field kenturish back
see you later
i got your ortega to raise your yard
second career walk off and what a day
for yadiel hernandez